lo que sigue a continuación es que
agentes de la agencia de cooperación
internacional junto con efectivos de la
Interpol así como personal de
cancillería peruana va a acudir a
California Estados Unidos para iniciar
los trámites de extradición Esto fue
anunciado previamente por el ministro de
Justicia peruano José Tello horas antes
de su entrega a los agentes federales en
Estados Unidos Alejandro Toledo le
exigió a las autoridades peruanas que le
otorguen el mismo trato que le están
brindando al expresidente Pedro Pablo
kuczynski es decir no una prisión sino
un arresto domiciliario Toledo ha sido
muy enfático al señalar que no solamente
se debe de investigar a su gobierno sino
a los gobiernos que
transcurrieron antes de su gestión
existen mucha expectativa por lo que
Alejandro Toledo le pueda contar a las
autoridades peruanas quizás a estas que
ya está bajo custodia Federal tratar de
Iniciar una negociación con la fiscalía
peruana para tratarle delatar a
Cómplices brindar información a fin de
que pueda obtener algunos beneficios de
pena de condena Toledo como se recuerda
está investigado por la fiscalía peruana
ya se ha iniciado un juicio en este país
y la fiscalía lo acusa de recibir
sobornos de la empresa constructora
brasileña odebrecht por 35 millones de
dólares para la construcción de la
carretera interoceánica que fue uno de
los principales orgullos del gobierno de
Alejandro Toledo al tratar de unir Perú
con Brasil a través de esta carretera
diversos colaboradores ante la fiscalía
peruana lo han denunciado a Toledo de
haber recibido estas coimas y usar a
testaferros para desviar los fondos a
través de cuentas
internacionalmente surcaron diversos
países hay muchos testimonios y Toledo
tiene mucho que responder a la justicia
peruana se ha anunciado que su esposa
Elián Card no va a venir y sobre ella
conjuntamente con Toledo hay otro
proceso que la justicia peruana está por
iniciar por lavado de activos Toledo
acudió a los agentes federales pero no
se entregó en la sede de la corte del
distrito Norte de California si no lo
hizo en otra jurisdicción Toledo se veía
según nos cuentan demacrado portaba una
casaca verde y estaba acompañado por su
abogada Mary goldman quien va a tratar
de
trazar estos beneficios para el ex
gobernante peruano